[Musique]
rosalie gâchette bonjour bonjour
monsieur librairie alors vous êtes chef
d'entreprise vous avez 54 ans vous êtes
mère de trois enfants vous êtes aussi
vice présidente de l'asso tamar et vous
êtes candidate à saint joseph vous allez
mener la liste à pdj l'assemblée
populaire démocratique joséphine
alors avant de parler de programme
et puis de votre motivation nous allons
d'abord faire connaissance qui êtes vous
exactement vous êtes chef d'entreprise
dans quel secteur alors déjà permettez
moi monsieur livory de dire un grand
bonjour aux martiniquais est
particulièrement josé fin alors comme
vous l'aviez dit je suis une demoiselle
bardel puisque les joues ces faits ne me
connaissent pas sur le nom de gâchette
et effectivement je suis chef
d'entreprise dans l'automobile
particulièrement et dans le btp
je suis aussi la vice-présidente de la
chope à mal depuis le temps de notre
ancien président depuis huit ans
maintenant et je milite pour l'écologie
pour l'environnement pour la protection
du patrimoine
alors qu'est ce qui vous a motivé
pourquoi vous présentez aujourd'hui à
saint joseph
pourquoi je me présente aujourd'hui à
saint joseph monsieur livory par
sentiment de devoir parce que j'ai vu la
souffrance des joseph m parce que j'ai
milité sur saint joseph alors avec mon
goût j'ai décidé de griller à une
assemblée populaire qui va rassembler un
petit peu les effets qui ont été
oubliées de la politique complètement
je suis justement monsieur libre et les
yeux les la bouche le nez les oreilles
de ce que qu'ils ne peuvent pas parler
qui ne peuvent pas s'expliquer qui n'ont
pas le droit de le faire pour quoi que
ce soit c'est pour cette raison que je
me présente aux élections en tant que
candidate avec le groupe à pdj alors à
pdj qu'est ce que c'est vous êtes
êtes soutenus par an par 10,2 sur bleu
quelconque
non non non je ne suis pas soutenu par
reparti la pdj c'est une liste citoyenne
démocrate que j'ai créée en tant
qu'association afin justement de militer
pour la cause des fn d'accord alors une
liste citoyenne ça veut dire qu'il n'y a
que des chefs de la faim de citoyen d il
ya des citoyens tous ceux qui sont
souffrants surtout à saint joseph
tous ceux qui veulent que ça avance et
tous ceux qui veulent pourra construire
la cité
alors vous vous êtes je les dis
vice-présidente de la soupe a marre et
l'association écologiste a beaucoup
mener des batailles sur saint joseph est
ce que vous étiez déjà en campagne en ce
moment alors pas du tout monsieur livory
à aucun moment je ne pensais être
candidate aux élections je soutenais
plutôt monsieur qui était avec nous
monsieur maurice mais malheureusement il
est décédé
et à partir de ce moment je me suis dit
non il faut que j'aille aux élections
afin de pouvoir porter ma pierre à cette
commune qui est en très grande
difficulté alors saint joseph c'est
particulier le maire est en grande
difficulté face à la justice
on ne sait pas encore s'il se présente
ou s'il va se représenter
comment vous voyez cette campagne alors
je vois que c'est une campagne où il ya
plusieurs candidats
nous allons faire parler la démocratie
et nous allons voir comment nous allons
lui candidat comme m6 j'ai envie de dire
c'est un peu beaucoup non ça fait partie
de ce qu'on appelle la démocratie et
c'est pour cela que nous appelons à pdg
d'accor quelles sont les grandes lignes
de votre programme
alors vous savez monsieur livory nous
avons une mairie où normalement le rôle
de la mairie de c'est de rendre service
à la population
mais s'il dans cette mairie de là elle
ne fonctionne pas convenablement un bain
rien ne peut fonctionner donc d'abord
nous allons faire une audite un autre
nous allons arriver à saint joseph afin
de pouvoir des tic déterminer le rôle de
chaque salarié
il y à des salariés qui sont qui fait
quoi qui on ne sait pas on ne sait
vraiment pas ce qu'il se passe dans la
mairie et à partir de ce moment nous
allons aussi recenser tous ceux qui sont
en dépression grande
et reste au niveau de la du personnel
municipal
donc nous allons faire ça avec notre
équipe et ensuite nous allons voir les
agricultures vous savez monsieur les
rues ils sont nombreux ils sont très
nombreux sur saint joseph
moi personnellement je ne veux plus
avoir à pousser mon chariot mon caddie
dans les lip service qu'est ce que je
vais avec notre sécu eh bien nous allons
mettre en place une coopérative et cette
coopérative justement permettra un
développement économique puisque nous
sommes le poumon de la de de la
martinique
un endroit où il ya beaucoup d'arbres un
endroit où il ya beaucoup de
l'agriculture est c'est pour cette
raison que nous allons employer
justement la méthode qui a été mise à
disposition de ces agriculteurs et les
aider à avancer
madame rosalie gâchette je vous remercie